- I've been up against
some of the most hardcore
people out there as you know.
The best thing you can do
is give somebody a dose of reality
and don't expect them
to change right away.
I've been to a Bernie Sanders Rally
and had a discussion
with a college student
during his last presidential run.
And by the time I was finished
with the conversation,
she said, "you know what?
The math doesn't add up."
I said, "good go figure
it out for yourself."
(gentle music)
I'm David Webb and welcome
to "Dave Rubin's Book Club."
Something I thought I would never say
in all our years of knowing each other.
Chapter seven, stop
hating straight white men,
America and Western values.
And my guest today, the
one and only Dave Rubin,
or am I your guest?
- We're each other's guests Webb.
We are changing the internet
by being civil to each other
even though people want
us to hate each other.
How about that, Huh?
- Well, they're gonna
fail miserably my friend.
And as people should now know,
we've been friends a long time
and we are aligned
but it's after five o'clock where I am.
So I'm toasting you with a Macallan 18.
Congrats on the book.
I will drink to it and never burn it.
- Right on brother, well I
can only do water right now
'cause I got a bunch
more interviews later,
but there we go.
So I wanna say that,
you were the perfect guy for this chapter.
We tried to select people
that obviously it made sense for each one.
But this idea of stop
hating straight white men,
America and Western values.
When you and I met, you know
many, everyone that's read the
book already knows the story.
I was a lefty, you were on the right.
We met in the hall at SiriusXM.
We struck a conversation, you said,
"Hey, why don't you come out to my show,
we'll debate some stuff?
We began doing that, we
did it pretty frequently,
we'd go out for drinks
after go out for dinner.
And there was no need to hate anyone
but David Webb, I'm a simple man
explained to me how it is,
that you don't hate straight white men.
It doesn't make sense,
that's what I'm told you're
supposed to do, David Webb.
How is it?
- I'll keep it really simple,
hate takes too much work.
All right, I know that's kind of a cliche
and people get that.
But why am I gonna spend
time trying to find a way
to hate a guy I meet in a hallway
on another channel which I'm
not supposed to agree with?
That's a lot of effort.
How about "Hey, your
name's Dave, pretty good.
"I'm a David let's not
get each other confused
(laughing)
"and let's just talk
about things that matter."
That's really how we met.
I wanted to talk to someone
who didn't share my
particular point of view.
You were willing to have that conversation
and here we are many
years later good friends
and we're actually two of the people
and I'm gonna give a lot of credit to you
'cause you took a bold step.
You've taken several bold steps Dave.
People will need to
understand, you stepped out
and you spoke for freedom,
you spoke for rationale,
you spoke for getting
out of an age of unreason
and go into an age of reason.
We've gotta get beyond this
and into deeper conversations
and that's what we need to do,
not just for America but for the world
'cause we set the tone.
- Yeah, so I'm glad you
brought up America there
because I know that we are both
deeply proud to be Americans
and that is something that.
- Absolutely.
- That is something that for some reason
the left which used to
be proud to be American,
seems to now take deep shame in that.
And it's like what?
What brings us together from,
for whatever our
immutable differences are,
who cares as an American?
And yet those ideas
seem to have taken root
in a really a perverse way.
- Yeah, it is perverse.
Think about what they've
tried to do to you
when you're out and your
speaking the Cancel Culture.
We're gonna shut Dave Rubin down.
Well, first of all you and I remember
someone that most people I hope
will get more familiar with
if you don't know him.
Andrew Breitbart, Andrew
said more voices not less.
Americans have said that
throughout our history,
even in our most visceral
maybe vitriolic disagreements.
But today it's canceled, today
you don't get an (mumbles)
You actually don't get an
opportunity to disagree today
and that's something
fundamentally anti-American.
It's what other people look
at us from around the world
and say, "I wanna be there
because I can do that."
My friends, my family overseas.
They love the fact that Americans
can argue with each other,
come up with 21 different
or maybe more opinions on something
and still realize that we're Americans.
- Can you talk a little bit about,
I mentioned three wake
up points in the book
and one of them is about you
and I was at "The Young Turks"
and we're watching a clip
and there's David Webb
and they didn't know I
was friends with you.
And they're calling you
and uncle Tom and a sellout
and a self hating black man
and all of those things.
Can you talk a little bit about
the slings and arrows that you've taken
because your Pro-American,
because you believe in the constitution
because you believe in freedom.
I always tell people when they say,
"I hate the phrase black conservative."
You're a conservative,
you happen to be black,
big damn whoop.
I mean, I, you know what I mean?
It's not that it has nothing
to do with your identity,
but you are, you are a
man first a human first.
But can you talk a little bit about just
that it's just because
you're sort of Pro-America
that they feel that they can
use your identity against you?
- Well, you know the first thing Dave is.
- I am, I'm sorry not your (mumbles)
your immutable identity yeah.
- Yep, Well look the skin
color is obvious, right?
That's the first thing.
Anybody walking down the
street can see your skin color,
my skin color.
Therefore really doesn't matter,
what they can see is what's in
our minds and in our hearts.
I've have these values
since my teen years,
and I developed more
along with the learning
and education that comes with
growing a little bit older
and learning more things.
I'm a Republican, you know
I'm someone who's proud
of the constitution,
proud of the country and our culture.
And that's why I am who I
am because I'm proud of it.
So I don't hate myself.
Whereby you know Dave, I
love myself way too much.
And there's
nothing wrong with that.
- I know you do.
Yeah, it's a, it's just a crazy situation
when you just say, "hey here, here I am,
"here's what I believe.
"I love my country and they
wanna come for you for that."
What are you saying?
- You know what, I love my country so much
and I rarely talk about this.
But at 17 years old,
I began a process of applying
to the Naval Academy.
I was deciding on colleges,
and yes because of my family history,
which goes back to the Revolution.
I'm actually a Son of
the American Revolution.
I'm the great great grandson
of a man who led a revolution
in Jamaica, Slave Rebellion.
I grew up with that
pride, I knew who I was.
So I raised my right hand,
I served only a short time.
I went to school, I make
no bones about that.
But I wanted to show
my love for the country
because of what I wanted
to do also for myself.
Which is very much a part
of what we do in America.
You can serve the country,
you can serve yourself,
you can serve your community.
It's not just about military.
It's about just being a good human being
and we've lost that too much.
But I'm telling you,
I'm gonna shock people.
I disagree with the overarching narrative
by the cacophony of
frankly overrated voices
who say that America's
bad, millennials are bad,
boomers are bad, all of this is bad.
Come on, you and I travel the country.
There were so many good
people in this country.
I've been in the Deep South,
I've been in rooms with racists.
Hi interviewed, this is,
I interviewed a member, senior
member of the Ku Klux Klan.
I've been to Vidor Texas.
I've been to so many parts of this country
and I've seen black, white,
every other dynamic play out
politically, culturally, you name it.
And you know what, I'm still here
because there are more
good people in Tupelo,
than they would tell you
in some parts of the media.
- You got, you got some tricks
on how we can get people
out of this mindset.
Because the reason I titled
the chapter like this,
Stop Hating Straight White
Men Stop Hating America
is that it seems like
it's just like this easy thing to catch
when you're a young person.
You live in this privileged place,
which I believe is the only
privilege there is in America,
is American privilege, it's
pretty freaking spectacular.
But they're, they seem like
they're very easy ideas to catch
that make you feel morally
good or something like that.
What kind of success
have you had, you know,
Deconverting people from
that, cause it ain't easy.
- No it's not and I'll tell you,
I've been up against
some of the most hardcore
people out there as you know.
The best thing you can do is
give somebody a dose of reality
and don't expect them
to change right away.
I'd been to a Bernie Sanders Rally
and had a discussion
with a college student.
during in his last presidential run.
And by the time I was finished
with the conversation,
she said, "you know what,
the math doesn't add up."
I said, "good, go figure
it out for yourself."
I don't try to convert
people, I talk to them.
I ask them what's important to them.
And I think if you engage people by saying
what's important to you, cool.
In other words, we're
going down a highway.
There's two cars, we're
in different lanes,
we're going down a highway,
there's a destination at the end,
but we have different lanes
and different approaches to
get into that same destination.
So does mine make sense?
Does yours make sense?
And if we can figure out
that's somewhere in
between these two lanes
is a middle lane, where we
can have the discussion.
Then maybe we can understand more
about what really matters
rather than focusing on
our individual choices
and look, I've changed my mind on things,
I've my eyes have been open,
there were smarter
people than me out there.
So I don't try to tell
somebody I'm smarter,
I just ask them to look,
look at the issue for what it is,
look in the mirror and be
honest with themselves.
It's what my father taught me.
He said, if you can look in the mirror,
if you can talk to yourself
and say, "I am confident
"I can back up my facts.
"I'm pretty sure."
And you know what?
Last part, if somebody brings
you a better set of facts,
then son, you've gotta
adjust your position.
- One of the things I've
been getting asked a lot
while I'm on this book tour
is why is it that people on the right
say, conservatives,
libertarians, old school liberals
seem much more open to the debate
and the discussion than people are left.
I have my own theories,
I wanna hear yours, but before I,
before I let you jump in on that.
One of the things that I've noticed is
every time I do your show
and throw it to the callers,
almost every single caller
says the same exact thing,
which is, "hey,"
there'll be saying it to either one of us.
They'll say "Dave or
David or both of you guys.
"I don't agree with you on everything,
"but I'm happy you're
having this conversation."
Do you think there is
an actual philosophical
or psychological reason
that people on the right seem
to be better at that right now
than people on the left?
- Yeah, I think there is,
and the way I've put it for years
is the liberal brain versus
the conservative brain,
not Republican versus Democrat,
but this unfortunately has changed
and I'm gonna change it now
for the very first time.
It's no longer liberal brain
versus conservative brain.
It's leftist brain versus
conservative brain.
'Cause liberal Ideas are not bad ideas.
We have differences in.
- You know who you're
talking to my friend?
- To the end goal.
- Yeah.
- But, you know the liberal
idea of learning more,
expanding your horizons, caring,
is no different than
the conservative idea.
The problem is leftists
have inserted themselves
the Anti-American, Anti-Freedom Crowd
and frankly they're cowards.
They're flat-out cowards
because they won't engage
in a debate of ideas
with somebody who disagrees with them,
back to the Cancel Culture.
If Dave Rubin decides to step out and say,
"I'm a gay man, I'm a gay married man."
And by the way, we joked
about this on "Late-Night TV,"
you remember that?
Hey David, if you had to be gay for a day,
who would you be gay with?
Dave Rubin.
Oh my God, he's got a sense of humor.
Hold it, black Republicans
aren't supposed to have a sense of humor?
These are people who are
fearful and hate themselves.
- I'm so shocked Comedy
Central let us do that.
(all laughing)
- But the thing is they took the chance
looking for the failure.
What did you and I do?
We prove that we could
sit there with others,
have a reasonable discussion
about our agreements,
disagreements and differences.
And when it came time
we found out we could
actually laugh together.
And you know, maybe it's
an old school phrase,
but laughter is the best medicine.
You can laugh at
yourself, laugh at things.
And along the way you'll find
that you have more in common.
- Yeah, what do you make about the,
the middle part of this,
which is that it's okay,
we say straight white men Western values.
But I think the part that
I didn't put in the title
that I think is the
underlying of all of this,
is sort of just the endless
attack on Christians
that we see.
That it's just like,
that's like just allowed
and I'm not you know look you
I think you should be able
to basically say whatever you want
and all that stuff
that you know my feelings
aren't free speech.
But just sort of like the mainstream,
like if you mock Christians,
you are applauded for it.
While if you were to mock any other group,
you would be lauded.
- Yeah, I, you know what,
I gotta say that, that one troubles me
and there are.
You know, there are
times when I look at it
and I go, what is your goal?
Are you going to try
to shut down this group
because they're Christian?
Are you trying to shut down somebody
'cause they don't care
the same way you do?
Well, the idea of freedom is that,
you know, I don't have
to agree with you Dave,
you don't have to agree with me,
but we have to respect
each other's rights.
And this is where you and
I aligned so perfectly
on the constitution.
Individual rights are not
crowd think or group thing.
Individual rights are our rights.
We do have limitations on
how you express your right.
We allowed Nazi's to
March in Skokie, Illinois.
But at the same time we
don't allow you to go in
and inflame the situation.
You know the shout fire in
a crowded theater approach.
So we've gotta walk a careful line.
But I'm not afraid
and unfortunately too many Americans
are afraid of the disagreement.
So they come out and they take it onto
let's attack Christians.
Why?
You know, turn the other
cheek, Christians are meek.
But the same cowards won't
go out and attack Muslims.
They won't go out and
attack another religion.
But they'll pick on Christians
and Jews and maybe Buddhists
and others who won't come back
because they don't fear it.
Well, you shouldn't need to fear it,
to have a discussion about it.
It's a level of cowardice
that we need to erase in this country.
- Are you hopeful that we
can reset some of this stuff?
I mean, people always ask me
if I'm an optimist or a pessimist
and I always say, well
I'm a World Weary Optimist
because I consider myself a Realist first.
But, but I don't think I
could wake up and write a book
and do everything that I do
if I didn't believe that what we do
can fix some of this stuff
can restore, you know pride in America.
An understanding of freedom and Liberty
and all of those things.
I suspect you're
ballparking in the same spot
as me on that, right?
- I'm not only the eternal optimist
and look, we all face challenges.
There are times when I'm sitting alone
or I'm thinking about
something and it gets me down.
It does, you know I'm human.
I sit there and I look at it
and I go, "how the hell do
I change this person's mind
"or these corporate people to think,
"or at least maybe not change their mind,
"but get them to think
outside themselves."
And as soon as I go there,
I remember basic lessons,
this country, this culture,
this Western value
system is founded on laws
that are set in place to
protect all the men and women,
to protect societies.
And yeah, our constitution
is different than the British
then the Australian
than other countries that
are in the Western hemisphere
of on the globe.
But for the most part,
we value the chance to be who you are.
The chance to debate someone,
the chance for freedom.
And that's what I
remember the basic rules,
the basic rules are, we've got
more in common in this life.
And if I don't like someone
or disagree with someone,
and I'm not pretending that
there aren't really bad people out there,
who need to be out, often
out of the conversation.
But if I vehemently disagree with you,
I still think fundamentally,
we have the right to live together
and exist together in a society like ours.
And you know what?
That debate actually excites me
and then all of a sudden
I'm out of that dark place.
And I'm out of that moment
when I'm so worried that
I become more hopeful
and I'm more hopeful because of (mumbles)
Guys like you like me,
we have a responsibility,
we have a megaphone, we have a microphone,
we have a camera, we have
what we're doing here.
And if we exercise that
responsibility more and more,
then there's other people
that will join in with us.
Because we are more than them
and we're gonna win this.
Webb, I know we should
probably end it there
because it was so perfect
but I wanna bring up one other with you
because it went viral
and I know that most of my
audience has heard it before,
but it's worth,
it's worth repeating again
because it actually capture
the essence of this chapter
more than anything else.
Can you explain what happened
in your radio experience
with Areva Martin who is a progressive.
Who actually had on "The Rubin Report"
way back when or many years ago?
She's a perfectly nice lady,
from my experiences with her.
But you were on the radio with her
and something interesting happened
and it gets to the exact purpose
of why I titled this chapter this.
- So Areva Martin smart woman,
Ivy league education,
lawyer, analyst for CNN.
Their team reached out
and wanted to come on the show
to talk about the nomination
of Justice Kavanaugh,
Now, Justice Kavanaugh,
we have the discussion.
In short they picked me,
I didn't pick them.
But because the discussion
went to something,
which Powdered or mirrored
what's supposed to be
the, you know, the white male dynamic,
White male conservative dynamic.
Without any hesitation
it was so easy for her to say to me,
"David, because you're a white male,
"you have white privilege."
Now thinking about that,
for anybody watching this for a second.
I'm gonna guess, you
know they're white cheeks
but they're not white cheeks.
And maybe they get me confused
'cause we're David and David.
- We got the contract up way high.
Yeah.
- What she did was so
easy and so sad in a way.
She not only couldn't do the research,
couldn't tackle me on the basis of ideas.
Me saying, I didn't believe
that my color of skin
was my primary driver to shorten it up.
But that she also had to go further
and throw our team under the bus.
So there's a fundamental
dishonesty about her.
She may be a nice lady,
I'm not gonna judge
her personal character.
I'm not gonna attack her
but she's an ill informed
and in many ways, a
willfully ignorant person
who's bound to a description
that has been fed her
or that she has absorbed into her person
and become someone who
judges by a broad stroke
and a false construct.
Its actually sad.
- It's actually fascinating.
Yeah, well it's so fascinating
because obviously it was radio not video,
so she assumes that you're
white by your thoughts.
Then when you say she threw
her team under the bus,
her response when you said,
"well, I happened to be a black man."
Her response was,
"oh, my people gave me
the wrong information."
As if any of us, when we go on a show,
they hand us a thing and it's like,
you talking to a white guy, he's 34
he's you know he's
heterosexual, blah, blah, blah.
But, but the reason I wanted
you to mention that again.
Is it, it's such a perfect encapsulation
of the whole chapter.
Because her implication
was your thoughts had to be
the thoughts of white men.
Thus they were wrong.
And then the second you
confront her on the truth,
she then throws her own
people under the bus
as opposed to rethinking her thoughts.
And if I'm not mistaken,
you did invite her
to Chat after that,
but nothing came of it.
Is that right?
No, I invited her back
Anthony and Edwin my
producers reached out.
We emailed her team.
She said on the show at
that time I would come back
because I would give her the microphone.
I would give her an hour.
I wanted her to come in studio,
so we could have a reasonable
discussion on this.
But you know, I've been
dealing with this my whole life
and I've watched it get worse.
So let's go back to the
subtitle of your book.
And I, by the way,
I borrowed the subtitle to
write in one of the articles,
"Thinking For Yourself
In An Age Of Unreason,"
I've watched an evolution
of the wrong voices
getting a majority, get in a big platform.
In college, my young years,
the decade since to where we are now.
These are people who should
not have a public forum.
Not because I wanna shut them down,
but they don't deserve one,
they haven't earned it.
And the fact that all my life
people have told me you shouldn't be.
My question is always,
tell me why I shouldn't be.
I didn't see in the books
where black people had to
be Democrats or on the left
and white people,
especially old white people,
had to be Republicans,
evangelicals and on the right.
I saw a part where this country has a flag
that we pledge our allegiance to,
that we raise our right hands
for those who serve in the military.
But that we all across this country
stand up and respect as a way that says,
"you know, this has a representation.
"The field of blue, the stars,
the blood that was shed."
So that we have the opportunity
to disagree with each other.
This is who we are human beings disagree.
They talk, they argue
sports, religion any topic
you and I have debated so many of them.
But we never walk away going,
I need to take you out of it
and I need to take you out.
I need to demean you and attack you.
And my audience loves you for that reason.
They love because
they don't actually see
the difference between us.
They see more similar things
between Dave and David.
- It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter my friend,
Webb, you're the best.
I appreciate you doing this,
and I look forward to
some whiskey in real life.
One of these days I suppose.
- Just for you Dave
and our late night chats many of them.
Yeah, the Macallan 18.
Here's to you, my friend.
Good luck, you don't need it
'cause you're so good at it
and to you, to family and to your dog.
Don't burn the.
- Right on.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our Politics Playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our Full Episode
Playlists all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the Notification Bell.